(rires)
- Une démonstration de force por
Danielle Smith au lendemain
de sa victoire.
La nouvelle cheffe voulait
rapidement réunir ir une cohésia
longtemps manqué dans le parti.
impression laissée par la
nouvelle cheffe semble réussie,
même si certains reconnaissent
qu'il y aura du travail à faire.
La course à la succession
de Jason Kenney aura été
acrimonieuse. Arrivé deuxième,
Travis Toews se fait aujourd'hui
les ponts au sein de son parti,
le ton est différent avec
le gouvernement fédéral.
La prochaine première ministre
albertaine maintient
la souveraineté sa priorité.
Déjà tendues, les relations
avec Ottawa pourraient encore
s'assombais)
Justin Trudeau estime quand
même qrains d'entente
sont possibles.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
- Pour livrer concrètement pour
rités des Albertains,
que ce soit lutter contre
les hausses du coût de la
de bons emplois.
(applaud(applaud(applaud(applau)
- L'opposition n'a pas tardé
à réagir au couronnement
À un peu plus de six moisdes pr,
la bataille est lancée et
la cheffe du NDP aeraineté
comme cible.
(en anglais)
Danielle Smith a gagné
cette course à la directio
en courtisant la base
la plus militante de la droite
albertaine, située surtout
Elle doit maintenant prouver
qu'elle peut dirigi
et gouverner une province
pour tous les Albertains.
difficile, mais pour Danielle
Smith, le plus dur est peut-
encore à venir.
Ici Mathieu Gohie